freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
video ihr wisst ja ich bin ein mensch
der restaurants liegt der essen liebt
dave ist ein mensch der mich liebt und
deshalb kann seine partei zwei
verschiedenen restaurants essen
bestellen ich weiß nicht welche es
sollte nach möglichkeit auch keine sein
die ich kenne ich sehr gut wäre büro
gemeinsam wir wissen was hier häufig
bestellen und ich werde dann probieren
zu erraten wie diese restaurants
bewertet sind also das ist die change
heute du hast quasi in der hand ob du
mich komplett hobbs nehmen willst mit
einem 0 1 sterne zwei sterne restaurant
oder was richtig geiles raus haus liegt
in deiner hand greift machst du jetzt
ich gebe dir mein handy und ich gehe aus
dem raum raus ist liegt nämlich
buchstäblich in deiner hand mein
liebster kulturhalle den raum so endlich
volle kontrolle über max kanal wir sehen
prinz to seek and max wunderbar warum
man es auch wunderbar oh mein gott das
problem ist wir haben halt schon so viel
gemeinsam bestellt werden schon so viel
alleine gestellt dass wir eigentlich
schon alles durchprobiert haben was in
irgendeiner weise gut bewertet ist das
bedeutet ein schlecht bewertet das
restaurant brauchen wir auf jeden fall
machen wir uns erstmal auf den weg ganz
ganz wach und mindestbestellwert 10 euro
chinesisch asiatisch 3,7 stern
pangora nasi goreng einmal nasi goreng
ein typisch indonesisches gericht haben
wir auch schon sehr häufig gegessen und
david marx bestimmt was zu sagen könnten
sagt noch zu früh ist schon bestellt
es kommt oder sollen den rest zu geben
das werk schon gibt und dass aus der
verpackung aus benehmen freddy schilling
zu müssen wir nur probieren dem bürger
so aussehen zu lassen als würde max ihn
nicht kennen denn es geht anderen bahnen
kein normales partie irgendwie sowas
kann ihn nicht zu umstellen
lutein freies position in einen puristen
also standard könnten auch einen veganen
bürger nehmen
das machen okay einen veganen bürger
dadurch könnte mag es vielleicht nicht
aufkommen woher der bürger kommt dann zu
sis kartoffelchips caesar salad ist
wahrscheinlich das einzige pleite in
paris unterwegs ist dann müssen wir die
bestellung so machen antipathie veganem
house pt guard petty konnte max kidd und
es ist soweit die erste bestellung ist
angekommen und eric hat sie hier unter
diesem paket versteckt ich habe wirklich
keine ahnung ich habe auch nichts
belauscht wirklich nicht herr kopf hören
deshalb kann so etwas riechen irgendwas
erkennen weil ich glaube ich würde sie
kennen möglicherweise zumindest was für
ein gericht ist na ja sehr schlecht er
warte warte ich habe eine vermutung ich
sagt während ich hochheben ok 321
friedrich schilling nicht dass der
bürger ist von frieder schilling
na klar nein und es ist auch unser
klassiker nein das werde ich hier
gemacht kein salat doch kleiner ceasar
salad vier euro 50 oder sogar meter ich
hab's das riecht so typischen zürich das
licht sehr sehr typ und mit beyond drauf
nehmen das ist nicht beyond mit sondern
das ist das vegane partie was aber nicht
mehr wie früher mit mir jetzt nicht mehr
man merkt ich habe da noch nie bestellt
aber ich weiß tatsächlich nicht wie die
bewertet sind plötzlich aber auch
einfach fragen können das hatte genau
den gleichen effekt hatten ja problem
beim bestellen ich habe mehrere ballette
durchprobiert wir haben angerufen ging
alles nicht mehr und mussten wir
eigentlich über eigentlich wollte von
anderen bürgerladen ausweichen aber es
ging nicht anders unheimlich probiert
ist die so schwer zu machen wie es geht
mit dem bürger aber zu erkennen was es
ist zu erkennen dass es ist nicht das
originale nicht original obama ist nicht
so originelle bild dieser diese
jahrzehnte war sie der kombination honig
käse apfel weil das riecht man einfach
man könnte fast meinen du bist
professioneller kochen ja das
ausprobieren scheiße trotz der noch habe
ich ja keiner gesagt ich probier s mal
herrlich frischer fehler ist dieses
petty zu bestellen weil ja nicht immer
üblich kein dieser zweite auch geil darf
für scheiße leicht was ich hab's einfach
gebrochen bevor ich hoffe also sehr
guter bürger land wir bewegen uns
garantiert zwischen vier und fünf stern
demnach sind auch sehr lecker des
herstellers was würde ich ja noch eine
tomate dich schließlich aus weil sie
dieses pad dem angebot haben und das
macht mich sauer und wenn ich jetzt auch
dazu bekannt fünf sterne auf lohnen
bekanntheits niveau zu halten ist noch
mal deutlich schwieriger als wenn du ein
paar bewertungen es gibt sogar bewährt
ja genau das dachte ich mir also
entweder vier oder 4,5 geht noch weiter
hinzu kommt das geht auf 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
hier kommen wir sechs oder sieben hier
noch ein bisschen es ist solide es ist
er einer der besten burger länder in
köln über jahre hinweg gehalten haben
also das was man nicht sehen kann beste
schläfer konzept garantiert nach besser
karton
der steht jetzt auch ein bisschen
trainieren das überhaupt nicht so oder
so ist eine klassische 4,7 der hack die
auflösung haben
38 war 3,8 oha ungerecht ja wirklich
ungerecht weil ich bin dave und ich bin
extrem lost die aufmerksame zuschauer
unter euch werden gemerkt haben dass
fertig sharing natürlich keine 3,8 stern
hatte sondern 4,6 was bedeutet dass max
nur 0,1 sterne mit seiner einschätzung
daneben lag ich habe die stelle vor mir
gehabt und habe es nicht mal hinbekommen
die abzulesen
ich hoffe er hatte trotzdem der menge
spaß es tut mir wirklich leid es war
komplett in grundsolider burger von dem
maschinellen konzept gut bergergut vegan
normal alles im angebot und dem 3,8
steht ihr leute verlasst euch nicht
immer auf die bewertung
probier doch mal aus ich bin gespannt wo
ich besser bin bei der nächsten 0,9 war
ich entfernt bis gleich was für ein
glück dass wir die andere bestellung
schon gegessen haben eine stunde 45
minuten und der typ nova tv und kein
essen dabei die idee haben muss nachdem
man kein wort der entschuldigung kein
licht wir wollten die anrufen keine
nummer online
wirklich ich weiß nicht was darunter ist
aber ich habe wirklich angst ich habe
auch tatsächlich noch nie von dem land
gehört wahrscheinlich auch nicht ich
auch so spaß mit ok sie denn wie ein
könig aus wenn wir ja es ist so es ist
ein standard verpackung für was für ein
gericht gebratenen reis gebracht
sowas dann schau doch mal ok oh nee wat
ich habe angst dass etwas in richtung
meeresfrüchte ist es nicht okay dann bin
ich froh weil von dem typen will ich
keine frankfurter block i angst jetzt
es sind meeresfrüchte das sind garnelen
ich bin extrem los hat mich meine nase
doch nicht im stich gelassen ist das ist
das nasi goreng nasi goreng okay das
riecht hat sie also jetzt kein scheiß
ich bin dem schon jetzt hier negativ
eingestellt aber ich schwöre es riecht
vergammeln das hätte ich jetzt glaube
ich nicht gesagt also ich werde glaube
ich so aus sicherheitsgründen vielleicht
nichts von den meeresfrüchten probieren
erstmal war eigentlich klar ich hätte
diese verantwortung nicht aus der hand
geben
unsere interessen und jetzt erstmal
nicht sagen würde ich ihm ein bisschen
meeresfrüchte abgekommen und mache ich
auch und was ist dass schinken schinken
ist glaube ich ein klassischer
bestandteil im nach sie korrekt ich
glaube auch leichter also ja hühnchen
ist auch drin
schmeckt nicht so viel kann man das hier
ist es schön aber ich sag mal ehrlich
wenn du das bestellst wenn du hunger
hast du warst 1 50 minuten dazu gibt es
schon mal prinzipiell nicht über der
goldenen mitte 2,5 sternen weil du bist
sauer wenn du hast bekommst ich war so
also noch durch war happy dass ich
fertig schönen davor hatte weil sonst
nicht mehr gestorben also villages
richtig böse geworden deshalb sind wir
auf jeden fall unter zweieinhalb stern
geschmacklich muss ich aber sagen ist
das nicht mal so fatal vielleicht weil
ich jetzt anderthalb stunden darauf
gewartet habe bin ich sehr negativ
eingestellt aber ich finde es fatal wenn
den zweck dass ich hatte halt schinken
garnele und reis er ist wird es ist eine
komposition aber es schmeckt einfach
nicht nicht also ich weiß aus meiner
erfahrung dass man keine ein sterne
restaurants findet es richtig dass geht
quasi nicht also jeder denn ein
sternerestaurant haben es um 89 auf ja
ich sag jetzt einfach straight auch wenn
es geschmacklich vielleicht so ein
bisschen besser ist 2,3 freddy schilling
hatte eine 3,8 ja dieses restaurant hat
eine
3,6 norway die 0 2 stelliger was okay
ich verstehe jetzt was du zeigen wollte
weil wieviel bewertung haben die 200 250
das hat nichts miteinander zu tun also
die sind meilenweit voneinander entfernt
schilling 20 wäre es beim bewerb im
ganzen tag ist den schlechtesten laden
genommen aber dann erklärt dass
zumindestens geschmacklich nicht so
quartal ist wie ich dachte also das ist
auf eine andere art und weise
interessant geworden als ich dachte
dieses video was hat euch gefallen da
gehörst du sehen was gut und bis zum
nächsten mal